[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome Sweetwater secrets live I'm
Liana Galera and y'all know Madeline
patch she's here I'm here thank you so
much for coming in again yeah thanks for
having me girl girl I adore you because
we've got to talk about today it's a
musical episode it's finally here the
fans are not ready you guys start
sending in your fan questions for the
lovely Madelaine we will be getting to
them soon the musical episode I've seen
it three times no way I've seen about
three now - yeah it's always on random
like a peewee fest I saw right before a
table read I saw and then one of the
time I saw and I was like I could watch
this all day it's I don't usually feel
that way about my own work yeah like
it's hard to watch my own work and then
that I was like oh my god I'm like I'm
living my best life watching it just as
I was when I did it and I think that's
what kind of like reads like you can
tell we all loved shooting it so much
where it's like all super excited the
whole time well and you got the
additional layer of like 70s glam I
think I know but like we show it's
really fun like the dancing like in
those bell-bottoms like also who knew KJ
Poe was like such a good dancer like
guys you have no idea like there's a
part in it where you will see what I'm
talking about between lily and KJ where
he like he was living his dream right
there Lily's voice though like I've
heard you sing we've heard kami seeing
so many times yeah got a little taste
from Lily but oh my gosh yeah so I lived
with her last season and like I would I
feel like I was waking up to the voice
of an angel because I could hear her
singing every morning it's like she's
got an incredible voice incredible yeah
and it's like been hidden for so long I
think it's gonna be like a huge shock
for people I think well and of course
you know I love every time then we get
to hear miss Cheryl sing milkshake is
still hands-down my favorite really even
hear her sing about okay but still she
was there I heard it but we don't really
hear you get to really hear her in this
musical episode we actually have a
special sneak-peek clip let's take a
look at the scene between shale and
Josie okay Cheryl I'm the only one
that's allowed to stop I think
yes I can't have you hating me while
we're singing a song about friendship I
know everything I did was legit crazy
Josie but I was wrestling with some dark
Carrie White like demons
I'm so so sorry
so please please forgive me do they
maybe sing this like we planned that I
forgot that's my no you you could never
let us down but I do love that we are
gonna get to see Josie and Cheryl really
addressed the fact that you know Cheryl
had a little bit of a crush right and
you know I think that like I'd like to
delve into that further at some point it
wasn't like I don't think it was like
your standard crush
obviously it was more of like an
obsession with the fact that somebody
cared about her and I tried to explain
that to people sometimes because it's
actually like when I say that it's very
deep when you like hear that Cheryl only
really was obsessed with Josie and
trying to stay keep her away from
chocolate because she wanted her for
herself which is a little like crazy but
to be fair it's cuz Josie's only person
who's ever showed her like a true
friendship and has cared about her she's
always had her back yeah yeah and so I
think Cheryl mistook that for something
else and was confused about her feelings
for women and but she was kind of
pushing those down because her mom
always told her to and so this is we're
muddled of stuff and whether they can
like squash the whole thing at Josie can
understand exactly yeah I love they were
speaking so quickly right now because
that leads us right into rapid-fire fan
questions um we had told the fans that
you were coming and we got a flood of
questions you guys booked on Twitter and
on YouTube so first up we have from 90s
ex says please ask her to confirm if
Cheryl was wearing Tony's pants at the
end of 2:17 and if that implies that she
slept over after they rescued her from
the nuns basically any backstory about
what happened after their rescue mission
look at the pants I know I already know
you're talking about so I you guys are
totally on it like I'm very impressed
that you figured that out yes so after
rescue being rescued from the nuns
obviously she didn't go back home to
thistle house yeah so Tony took her in
and for the next like I think 1718
Cheryl's wearing only Tony's clothes
because she's staying at Tony's so it's
kind of like a little note to it we
don't only talk about it at all but it's
nice you guys notice those things good
job how do you like wearing Tony's
clothes those pants I don't know how she
wears them all the time I was sitting
and I got got up and I took the pants
off and I had like giant ring marks in
my leg I was like ah but they're really
cute yeah very cute clothing she is
really good clothes on this I mean like
next up we have at Mads underscore
vixens she says which episode do you
think Shoni shippers will love the most
by the end of the season I don't know
they're all really good I think to 20
which is 8 to 22 I think to 22 is really
oh the finale I think you guys are gonna
like the finale like the finale he's
just got everything you could possibly
want of it which is amazing
give us all those all those little showy
morsels until season 3 oh I love this
handle at oh my Madeline that's cute
wants to know what was your favorite
Cheryl line of all the episodes oh the
us just saw it in 217 I mean just
because it's all on the top of my head
I'm just going to say this one but when
I say this school's gonna burn really
yeah because I did not like lying
probably 18 times they wanted to want to
do anything under the Sun so we can
decide which what direction we want to
go in and they went with the serious one
like the super serious like I'm really
gonna burn the school now look before we
went live Mads and I were talking about
how one of my all-time favorite lines is
inner circle cousin Betty that is a
great one too right maybe that is I
don't know man I got some good life too
I really do thank you Roberto and all
writers for that because yes it's it's
we also have some great YouTube comments
right now as I'm getting a phone call a
phone call no it's just this
telemarketers so we have a youtube
comment from ana and she says did you
see Cheryl join oh do you see Cheryl
joining serpents I mean Cheryl doesn't
have any kind of loving family maybe the
Serpent's can make her feel more lovable
by the way Nana Rose should also join
the Serpent's I would be so happy
okay I am so on board with Nana to Rose
door and serpents like imagine Anna and
like a bat mi7 arm that were bad bad
blank I'm tired jacket bad but leather
jacket
their jacket yeah that would be great
does that be it nice a nice community
like for her and like a camaraderie that
she's never felt and could definitely
use yeah yeah Caitlyn Conway wants to
know what has been your favorite moment
between Cheryl and Tony and she adds I
love you so much Wow God you know I have
to say my favorite is still the kiss at
the sisters of quiet mercy I think
that's just such a tender and sweet
moment that Cheryl has never had on the
show every kiss she's had has been not
either messy with mousse or it was like
trying to force Archie to something he
wasn't interested in because he was
confused and so this was like a nice
leap moment for someone to actually come
save her and like want to kiss her yeah
and then also when they're sitting on
the couch like playing with each other's
hands and stuff they're like you know
cute couple II honeymoon stuff it like
that I still love knew you were gonna
say that
I called you from the beginning yeah
Gray said we were going to go together I
had you in yeah okay and I was like
maybe Neos anything could happen in
Riverdale that was like anything's
possible in Riverdale and at that point
already knew it was going to happen last
fan question from you to Edith I don't
know how last name Edith but Edith wants
to know what was your favorite seemed to
shoot of the season and is Sheryl going
to do something about Claudius and her
mom TBD on the second half of that um
first half favorite scene to shoot
probably anything in the musical episode
I'd say the ending of the musical
episode for Sheryl was my favorite
really but I can't tell you guys why
cause it's over but bringing it back to
the musical episode mm-hmm this was such
a unique and fun moment it could have
just been that they were gonna sing only
when they're on the stage but they
really went there a little bit like
we've seen in the special sneak-peek
clips that they've been singing as
they're like getting ready yeah what was
that like for you when you realize like
oh no we are gonna do a true musical it
was just nice I feel like the reason why
I think music Allah is just such an
excellent episode and it's kind of a
standalone like I feel like if you
haven't seen Riverdale you've been
living under a rock you could turn on
the TV and you can see this this musical
episode and you could still love the
show and be able to follow along whereas
I feel like a lot of our episodes have
you have to watch back to back yeah this
one really does stand alone I'm proud of
everybody's working it I love it was
that the question
yes great yeah no you're great
Nadine from facebook wants to know how
has life changed for you since being
cast in Riverdale man
Nadine that's a very large loaded
question essentially completely
different
I was working three jobs to pay my bills
and now I work with Roberto only and I
have fans and that's kind of like
anything for me yeah so a lot there's a
lot everything's different well and you
also have a lot of new exciting
opportunities coming up right now
what a great segue I I designed my own
sunglass line guys thank you oh those
are huge
oh I'm loving the the blossom color I
remember the pink oh oh I've got a red
pear girl I've read and I have a
colorway of red for every single frame I
made just because because of Cheryl but
I also like you have like a cute little
cage I'm really excited oh my love
yeah where can fans get these they are
in Prive revoke aam oh yeah and Amazon
I chose Amazon because it's a worldwide
shipping and also because Amazon's just
so great for everyone I feel like
everyone has Amazon like the app and
whatever so these are the rogue I'm
pretty into these these are the candy
style those are the ones you gave to
Lily mm-hmm I don't actually I just
follow Lily's Instagram cuz it's awesome
I follow oh yeah we have a lot of fun
pairs over here today I had a lot of fun
doing this - yeah this is like my if I'm
not wearing makeup and like going to the
airport pear oh you know those are I'm
like you can't even see the eyebrows yes
do them the whole half of my face is
covered it's great last pair I feel like
this is like Christmas like this one oh
yeah very round I love those are very
fun these are like sixties right they're
all kind of inspired by time stuff like
I just like I like big and I like small
obviously so I just wanted to make it
all there's one for every mood oh
there's one for every mode there's five
different colorways for what but you are
on hiatus right now mm-hmm but you're
not really getting too much of a break
what is it like for you to still have
your life revolve around Riverdale but
you're not shooting yeah I mean I'm not
just doing Riverdale stuff I'm also like
you know doing the sunglass line which
makes it which keeps it like in fresh
still I feel like I did press week for
my son lost line in New York last week
and then I went to Chicago to meet a
bunch of fans at fan fest for River
and it's like I think I have a nice
balance of personal yeah of like my own
stuff and then of riverdale to like
really feel like a well-rounded human
it's important to like go work out you
know we were talking about this before I
we got on live like I I work out every
single day with my trainer and it's like
you're crushing it thank you oh is hard
I went to a 6:30 a.m. workout class this
morning cuz I'm like Mads is coming I
gotta get there's no way I can't by the
way I had to get up at 6 a.m. this
morning and I don't get up at 16 and I
felt like I was like like Gollum like
getting out of bed like crawling on the
floor like I can't do this anymore
Liam from YouTube wants to know Madelene
is there going to be any more Cheryl and
Archie moments even though I adore Shoni
are there any more moments between you
and KJ no sorry yeah I don't need
friends yeah yeah I don't need him I'm
happy with this what she's got now I
know that you meant that platonic or not
but yeah hard less it's like they'll get
it who would you like there's like he's
around and stuff but yeah there's not
like any one-on-one interactions who
would you like to see Cheryl share more
scenes with man I'm miss Schoenberg
Veronica like I missed that they have
like a fun and nice friendship a season
one mm-hmm like the three girls like
yeah we should rescued her yeah but it's
well I need more of that I want more of
that like female friendship thing I'm
all about girls supporting girls yeah
it's like I I think we need more of that
well and that's why I feel like I was so
frustrated with Ethel in the musical
episode and you guys will be too we saw
one of the sneak peak Clips like that
somebody cuffed under their breath tone
yes she's never even heard Sherrill
scenes yeah say see anything no saying
which is just it's just like you know I
guess it goes with the territory of like
there's always gonna be that one person
who's gonna bring you down and like
Cheryl's live that her entire life so
but shows also been the person bringing
other people down so it's like it's a
weird it's a weird thing I still was
laughing so hard at the couple's retreat
you just dropped that bombshell
yeah but boy can you imagine walking up
to a group of people you call your
friend and asking to go with them on
this thing am I making yourself
vulnerable and then then being like sir
come on I'm a boyfriend or a girlfriend
it's like okay well guess what I'm a
ruin your vacation bomb dropped um I
love that you just said girlfriend or
boyfriend because so look at this
adorable playbill the CW sent me okay
because there's a little thing that I
want to read in here because um they all
have a little cast BIOS and I'm gonna
read out out Cheryl's I had me I shoulda
read this before we did this okay Cheryl
blossom is oMFG excited to play cult
icon role and carry the musical she
would like to thank the cast and crew
for their love and adoration and send
granby says to her girlfriend yes her
girlfriend tawny topaz when did the
title happen on this relationship status
there's actually a scene that was ended
up being cut that was like a
confessional what I call her my
girlfriend and that so that I think
that's kind of where it happened and
both Tony are I'm sorry Vanessa and I
were like oh yeah we're in a
relationship like we were really excited
about it but I think first Cheryl
because she's never been in a
relationship he's never been with
anybody and it's such a nice new like
fun thing for her I think I just like
the minute they kissed they were in a
relationship for Cheryl and I think like
that this is like her way of like
confirming it to Tony but they're like
already kissing in public like you know
they're on that so they're great I just
never want anything to happen to them
but riverdale so who knows the slow burn
was killing me in the moments and the
episodes leading up to it like they made
me give him 6 to like 15 that's a long
time that's 9 episodes with plenty of
breaks in between oh yeah oh all these
you know all those breaks it was killing
you when I don't which was killing me to
keep the secret yes it's true the
Sweetwater secret yes oh she's plugged
our name yeah we are running out of time
but we have one more question on here
that I actually really love because it's
from Sheryl blossom on YouTube okay she
says hi I love you Mads because you love
Halloween
yeah I do too and here's my question if
you could dress up as any riverdale
character for Halloween who would you be
in why love you and your kindness oh and
uh Alana from Facebook loves the
sunglasses
ah thanks Lana from Facebook that one
I'm gonna get this by the end of it
alive which is right now um what would
be my do dress up for Nana Rose I would
say Nana rose
yeah yep that's the move army crawl I
would run all I would do as my dress up
is just army crawl and regular clothes
with no contact and no white white white
hair I would just be crawling around
trick-or-treating as a 23 year old woman
angle can we just take a moment to thank
me on the roads for being the og Shoni
shipper honestly yeah like to you yeah
yeah I didn't just do that what happens
when I get eight hours of sleep
yeah I'm saying it's too much
oh I'm not used to as much sleep so I'm
like off the wall so now unfortunately
we are out of time oh no no um for all
you fans you're tuning into secrets live
thank you so much and thank you as
always as always I've snuck some bonus
questions in from meds that you will get
on later episodes of Sweetwater secrets
so keep it tuned and watch the musical
episode tonight at 8 p.m. on the CW bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you